chipping away at the narrative requires
discomfort one way is to stop doing
things that serve no purpose except to
feed the narrative and people's neuroses
like wearing a mask outside be kind but
firm takes courage but creates courage
in others months ago in phoenix a few
stopped masking and now masks are rare
i think this is true for some things and
won't work for some others right and i
mean i do think the question of outdoor
masking
uh has for us always been so obvious and
straightforward that um i think i may
have mentioned
um
i don't know when it would have been
at some point uh probably pre-vaccine
stuff so maybe like
14 months ago or so i was walking in
some park that i love
with wide paths
you could easily stay away from people
and
some woman with a mask
yelled in my direction um that's uh
someone behind me who was also masked
thank you for wearing a mask like well
that was not only not direct to me but
clearly passive aggressive and obnoxious
and uh you know i thought about trying
to engage her and it's like no i'm just
i i refuse to wear a mask outside we do
still wear basks inside as we are um
supposedly required to in the state of
oregon i would say we wear them inside
when required yeah we wear masks inside
when when required
two we are beginning to hear
uh tales of
outside
in other areas
in oregon especially just even even
really just outside of portland um some
places not um not requiring them um but
the signs on every store here is of
course you know according to the
governor's orders everyone must be
massed to come inside the store
yeah but i think there is a question
here because um
as we've mentioned before the evidence
that cloth masks work is extremely thin
and the evidence that others how their
masks work is
dependent on them being worn uh in a
particular way and the chances that this
is actually
a place where
um
you know it makes sense to have this
kind of authoritarianism is pretty low
so the question is
i know that personally
i wear them when required to because i
am not interested in sending a signal to
my
fellow citizens that i am defecting on
them that i am in any way callous about
their well-being i would absolutely give
the middle finger to the authorities
that require these things when it
obviously isn't about health or they're
so inept that they don't know
you know that they should be telling you
uh go outside and delight in the fact
that you don't need a mask there so the
point is but but there but i i can hear
the argument from some people that will
say
um
these are the same people who think that
you are defecting on them by not
becoming vaccinated right therefore you
know how how is this any different well
because
the point is
we are being dragged into a signal
the signal of the mask it is the signal
of a cult
i don't wish to broadcast that signal at
all
now my vaccination status is nobody's
business really now again there are
circumstances in which a particular
disease with particular public health
authorities and a particular vaccine
could justify a mandate so i'm not
opting out on
that but i guess my point is
because the vaccine status is not
obvious anywhere
this is a much more ambiguous thing but
well so in in california in oregon in
washington uh you have to wear masks to
go into into retail businesses
regardless of your vaccination status in
california and one or two other states i
think at this point apparently the
signage and the rules are people who are
vaccinated don't have to wear masks
inside
and um and
by and large we hear they don't check
but you know they could right and
um i guess i
i
i'm not
i don't see
the level of difference that you do
between these two things even as i
continue
to you know i continue to behave the way
i have from the beginning i put on the
mask at the last possible moment before
going in and rip it off as soon as i
leave and get some dirty looks from
people because you know
you're still close to the store how
could you be unmasked but you know
whereas the most of the country at this
point isn't having to wear masks at all
and they're you know so
masks these masks the way that they are
being employed and the kinds of masks
that people are wearing are very much
like these vaccines in that they
apparently aren't doing the job that
we're being told they do they are
signifiers of compliance uh but they are
uh inaccurate signifiers of uh health
protection yes they are signifiers of
compliance and in fact there are
signifiers of compliance with
nonsensical health advice right and um i
would point people i haven't been fully
through it yet but people should look at
chris martinson's recent interview on um
mass formation and the idea that
actually the
nonsensicalness of the rituals is a
feature not a bug
but anyway
the point i would make is we are
actually somewhere else the the
conundrum
of what to do about the mask or
more to the point the vaccine mandates
is in some ways not well addressed by us
at all
it really needs to be addressed by
people who
have been compliant
right in effect what we need is for
people to recognize that the mandates
themselves
are
um a breach of our social contract with
each other as we discussed uh in the
first part of the podcast
and the point is um
if i was to
go to a store
right let's say
you know the store said that whites only
right
i'm not going in that store right it
doesn't matter that i may technically
qualify i'm not going in that store
because i don't respect it now if the
government issued a mandate that said
actually we need to segregate for
whatever reason so you know blank and
black you know on thursdays these stores
will be whites only so
the only thing that was happening is the
store was complying i'm still not going
into the damn store right and so i think
the point is the rebellion
has to occur against the mandates and it
should unify those of us who are
unvaccinated with those of us who are
vaccinated because clearly the
circumstances does not justify this and
we are being segregated from each other
for reasons that have not been shared
with us and so the point is this is all
immoral you're wrecking our civilization
and you don't have a right to do it so
none of us are going to participate
right that's the answer to this and if
you know the 30 of people who actually
believe this garbage and you know
haven't noticed all of the paradoxes if
those 30 are still gonna participate
fine but you know
they can't they're not a civilization
yeah they're not
um
i'm still i can't remember if i talked
about this on air a week or two or three
or eight or something ago but um you
know one of the things i loved most
about moving to portland was the
prospect of live theater which i've
always always loved and my parents lived
in london for many years every time i'd
visit we we'd see a lot and
i grew up in l.a seeing a certain amount
and there was a little bit in ann arbor
and we lived there but there's none
olympia
um so i went many many years without
basically having access to much and we
had
we had been seeing live theater and when
coveted hit and the tickets that i had
bought
um you know disappeared into thin air
um
i
i said to the theaters in question um
hold on to my you know because they were
desperate and we were i felt so so bad
for for the artists and the other other
live
the people who were doing work that
required that you'd be live in person
with people
but especially the artists and musicians
and such um and said you know hold on to
my money until until you can perform
again and then and then i hope to you
know use i hope to come back and be in
person and
they're finally opening up um but it's
they aren't saying you can't come if
you're not vaccinated
but they are saying pufa vaccine or uh a
negative test within some number of
hours and
that means that technically we could we
could go
but i i guess
for me i felt like
i was i was one of the staunchest
supporters of and i
will remain
of the creators whose work depends on
being in person with people because we
all need that we all need again to
reclaim our sense of collective joy and
be together in person experiencing
something collectively
and it's those organizations that went
the most woke the fastest during you in
the aftermath of george floyd and that
have now been you know most eager to go
with medically woke pronouncements in
some places i've heard that you know you
can't even do a negative test um but
frankly the oh yeah all you have to do
is do a negative test really for all
four of us for like and you know in what
time frame and
you know [ __ ] you
frankly yeah well no
no
no i think this is exactly right and
the
the problem
is
i don't want to do anything that signals
that i believe in the fiction i also
don't want to signal that i ever thought
covid wasn't serious or was it
self-efficient right the point is
it was a serious disease we now know a
lot about how to treat it there are
certain people who are blocking our
access to the things which would be
useful in that battle and forcing us to
do things that are pointless
and then also blocking us from
joyous human experience right and so you
know
let's put it this way these people
have the equivalent
of
an emblem like nike's swoosh right it is
the mask
and they are causing even those of us
who detest them
to broadcast their advertisement and to
signal that we are compliant with the
such and such and so okay
maybe you don't have to be vaccinated
but then you're going to need a test and
the point is
this is all predicated on the idea that
you need protection from me right i
think the opposite is more likely to be
true yeah and
in fact there's a question to that
effect here
you can keep let me just see if i can
anyway i think the point is look
the time
they're vaccinating children with a
vaccine that does not
aid children they are vaccinating
against them
against a disease that does not harm
healthy children
and they are vaccinating with a
a vaccine that even if you granted them
everything we know nothing about its
long-term implications which matters
more for children because they have
longer lives ahead of them right
when you then add in what we do know
about
growth phase and so injury may proceed
faster right depending on what kind of
injury it is obviously not in the
children's interest as far as we can
tell compare the disease to the vaccine
obviously not in the children's interest
therefore it is immoral so the point is
that's the people whose
brand we're now broadcasting with our
masks and who's fiction about who's
dangerous to whom we're going to signal
that we accept by you know ponying up a
test that says that we are in fact free
of covid no the fact is
we know how to deal with this disease
it's now manageable right the tests are
crap the vaccines are crap your
indicator of compliance is just that
because the indicators themselves are
demonstrably crap demonstrably crap and
and bad for people and enough already
and so the point is yeah somehow what i
want what i want to figure out
is some way to broadcast
i am no longer putting up with this [ __ ]
without broadcasting i don't take you my
fellow citizens health seriously because
i do take that seriously but i do not
take these authorities these authorities
need to be taken seriously in a very
different way they are they are a menace
to civilization and they
need to be removed yesterday so that we
can get something like a proper response
and get back to a functional
civilization you know you can't turn it
upside down over myths
watch them well yeah watch them
[Music]
you